hey guys i'm alan and welcome to my
channel where today you're about to
watch
a um stream highlight that i decided to
clip out because it was a very like
cool positive moment for me and i just
try to
share things when i feel really
positively about them especially when
youtube can be a place where people feed
off of so much negativity all the time
but i felt like i should make this uh
before bit
um because to a lot of people this video
won't make any sense and i can't even
figure out how i'm gonna title it in a
way that would even make any sense
but for anyone who's not aware uh
i play an npc i i voice a character
and um was modeled to be in cyberpunk
2077. that means that i sent cd projekt
red
a bunch of pictures and uh they
had to recreate me in the game
but it does mean and i could be
completely wrong about this but i'm
pretty sure i'm right
um i'll have side by side photos that
this reaction is to an asset that was
created to look
exactly like me um not something that by
coincidence looks like me
if i have that timeline correct i'm not
positive but yes wanted to give you that
explicit context first so people aren't
like what
that why is she reacting that way to
something that just vaguely looks
similar
all right here it is thank you i feel
like i can
find something i like more you know you
know i'm gonna try not to spend too long
here i promise
that's cool too what are you a part of
one
that one is really good so our eleven
remember eleven
[Music]
that's me when i was thirteen one
hundred
100
you want to listen to my chemical
romance in your spare time
see i like these ones as well though i
feel like it suits it
that's pretty cool
i'm still partial to 11 though
that's my hair that's just 100 my hair
a thought has occurred that could
actually be my hair
you know that actually could be the hair
that they used
when they made me in the game
right
let me look at my picture hang on i'm
like because i feel like it's not that
different
like that could literally
actually be my hair in the character
creator
it totally is oh my god
when i oh my god that's so cool
that i like jump into this and i'm like
that looks pretty similar to my hair
it's because it [ __ ] is my hair like
that's that's so cool um i would just
like you all to know
that hairstyle 31 was literally
from pictures of my face
okay i'm not doing it though that would
be narcissistic and ridiculous
but holy [ __ ] that's cool oh my god
amazing okay uh or it could be that one
i suppose
could be either could be either but i'm
taking ownership of it